hi everyone so nice to see so many
familiar faces and glad we haven't
scared you off yet
so today I'm gonna be talking about an
extension on a lot of the computer
vision techniques that Avila was
discussing in the previous lecture and
specifically focusing on a class of
learning problems for generating new
data and we refer to these problems or
these models as generative models so
these are actually systems that don't
actually look to only extract patterns
and data but they go step beyond that
and actually use those patterns to
actually learn the underlying
distribution of that data and use it to
generate brand new data this is an
incredibly complex idea and it's
something that we really haven't seen in
this course previously and it's a
particular subset of deep learning and
machine learning that's enjoying a lot
of success especially in the past couple
years so first to start off I want to
show you an example of two images so
these are two faces and I want to take a
poll now about which face you guys think
is fake which is a which face is not
real so if you guys think that the left
face this one is not fake how about you
raise your hands sorry
fake okay I think like 20 30 percent
okay how about this one okay that's a
lot higher interesting okay so the
answer is actually both are fake okay
so this is incredibly amazing to me
because both of these faces when I first
looked at them first of all incredibly
high dimensional they're very
high-resolution and to me I see a lot of
details in the faces I choose a wrinkle
structure I see shadows I mean like I
even see coloring in the teeth and
special like defects in the teeth it's
incredibly detailed what's going on in
these images and they're both completely
artificial these people don't exist in
real life so now let's take a step back
and actually learn what is generative
modeling so generative modeling is a
subset of unsupervised learning so far
in this class we've been dealing with
models which are focused on supervised
learning models so supervised learning
takes as input the data X which we've
been calling it and the labels Y it
attempts to learn this functional
mapping from X to Y so you give it a lot
of data and you want to learn the
classification or you want to learn the
regression problem for example so in in
one example that Abba gave you give it
pictures of the road from self-driving
car and you want to learn the steering
wheel angle that's a single number
that's a supervised learning problem now
an unsupervised learning we're actually
talking a complete tackling a completely
different problem we're just giving it
data now and we're trying to learn some
underlying patterns or features from
this data so there's no labels involved
but we still want to learn something
meaningful we want to actually learn
some underlying structure that's capable
of generating brand-new data from this
from this set of inputs that we receive
so like I said the goal here is to take
training examples from one input
distribution and actually learn a model
that represents that distribution once
we have that model we can use that model
to then generate brand new data so let
me give you an example we can do this in
one of two ways the first way is to
density estimation so let's suppose I
give you a lot of points in a one
dimensional grid drawn at random from
this distribution that I'm not showing
you but I'm giving you the points here
can you create this density function
just by observing those points so can
you observe the underlying dis
abuse that generated those points if you
can create this probability distribution
here
well now you can actually generate brand
new points according to that
distribution another example more
complex example is using sample
generation so now you're not focused on
only estimating the density of this
function but now you actually want to
generate brand new samples go go
straight to the generation portion so
here I give you a lot of training
examples which are just images on the
left hand side right here and these were
drawn some sorry these were drawn from
some distribution which we'll call P
data okay this is a probability
distribution of the data and we want to
generate brand new training examples
that are drawn from another distribution
which we'll call from the probability of
the model the probability distribution
of the model and our goal in this whole
task is to actually learn a probability
distribution of the model that is as
similar as possible to the probability
distribution of the data so when we draw
samples from the model they almost look
like they were being drawn from the
original probability distribution that
generated the real data so why do we
care about actually learning the
underlying model here one really good
example is something that you'll get
exposure to in the lab that Abu is
mentioning where we're doing facial
classification for D biasing the key
aspect of D biasing is K is being able
to learn the underlying latent variables
intrinsic within the data set a lot of
times when we were presented with a
machine learning problem we're given a
lot of data sometimes it's not properly
vetted or labeled and we want to make
sure that there are no biases hidden
inside this data set so sometimes you
might see that maybe if you're given a
data set of a facial classifier you're
given a lot of faces and a lot of not
faces you want to learn now a classifier
to predict faces maybe all the faces
that you're given are falling from one
distribution that is not actually
representative of the real distribution
that you want to be testing on so let's
suppose maybe you have a lot of faces
from one ethnicity or one gender type
can you detect in an unsupervised manner
by learning the underlying distributions
without being told
to look for something like gender or
ethnicity can you just learn this
underlying distribution of the data and
then use that distribution during
training time 2d bias your model this is
something that you'll get exposure with
during the lab today and you'll actually
do biased biased facial classifiers that
you'll create another great example is
for outlier detection and it's actually
a very related example to the D biasing
one that I just gave here the problem is
a great example of the problem is in
self-driving cars so when we're
collecting self-driving car data we
collect a lot of data that looks
extremely similar so 95% of the data
that we collect is probably going to be
on very simple roads straight roads
maybe highway driving not very complex
scenarios and not really interesting
scenarios not the edge cases that we
really care about one strategy is to use
generative modeling to detect the
outliers here so we want to learn the
underlying distribution of the data and
then actually understand that when we
see events like this can we detect that
they are coming from the tail end of the
distribution that we should pay more
attention to these points instead of
always focusing on the very simple or
not complex examples which are coming
from the main mode of the distribution
so let's start discussing two classes of
models that we'll talk about in this
lecture the first being auto-encoders
and variational autoencoders the second
class of models I'm probably sure that
you've all heard of is called generative
adversarial networks and that's what was
creating the faces that I showed you on
the first slide
both of these models are classes of
latent variable models so let's actually
start by talking about what is a latent
variable I saw some giggles so does
anyone know what this image is yeah okay
nice so this is an image of it's called
the myth of the cave it's from one of
plato's books I believe and I'll quickly
describe what's going on in this image
it's a great example I think of
describing what is a latent variable and
maybe this helps motivate why we care
about latent variables even further
so in this example a group of prisoners
is actually chained their back start to
a wall and they're forced to look only
forward and they can see these shadows
projected onto the wall but they can
only see the shadows they'd never see
the actual objects behind them that are
generating the shadows because of this
fire to those prisoners the shadows are
the observed variables they can measure
them they can give them names even
though they aren't real objects they
aren't the real objects that are
underlying what is actually projected
onto this wall but because that's all I
can see that is their reality that's
their observations they cannot directly
observe or measure the true objects
behind them because they can't turn
around but they and they don't actually
know that these things are shadows they
have no concept of that the latent
variables here are like the objects that
they cannot directly observe but are the
ones that are informing or generating
these shadows so in this case the
observable variables just to reiterate
once again are the shadows that the
prisoners see the hidden variables are
the latent variables are the underlying
variables or the underlying objects that
are generating these shadows now the
question here is going back to like a
deep learning frame of mind can we have
learn the two variables the true latent
variables from only observable data so
if I give you a lot of data can you
learn some underlying latent variables
from that structure so to start with
we're going to talk about the first
class of models which is called
auto-encoders it's a very simple
generative model which actually tries to
do this by encoding its own input so
just to reiterate let's suppose we want
to have an unsupervised approach
remember again this is all unsupervised
so we're not given any labels here so we
don't know that this is a - we're simply
given an image and we don't know what it
is now we want to feed these raw input
image pixels and pass it through a
series of convolutional layers in this
case let's suppose just because this is
an image so the green the green layers
here you can see our convolutional
layers let's suppose
and you're going from your input X
through convolutional layers to this
output latent variable which we'll call
Z you might notice here that the latent
variable is much smaller than that of
the observed variable and then actually
this is a very common case so we're
calling this this model that I'm showing
here an encoder so this is encoding your
input X into a lower dimensional latent
space
Z and now I actually want to raise a
question to see how many of you are
following me why do we care about having
low dimensional Z's in this case is it
important that we have a low dimensional
z does it not really matter why is it
the case that usually we care only about
low dimensional Z's yeah exactly
yeah so I think so the suggestion was
get rid of noise that's a great idea by
getting along the same lines I think
what you're getting at is that you want
to find the most meaningful features in
your input right that are really
contributing to what's going on what's
underlying this data distribution pixels
are incredibly sparse representation of
images and often we don't need all that
information to accurately describe an
image so in this case this - it's found
that you can usually model n this digit
so that these images are drawn from the
data set called amnesty which is just
handwritten digits you can usually model
endless digits with about five latent
variables and these are images with
hundreds of pixels in them but you can
compress them down and very accurately
describe them with just five numbers so
doing this actually allows us to find
the most accurate or sorry the most rich
features in the image that accurately
describe and abstract away all of the
details underlying that image so how can
we learn this late in space I mentioned
it's not a supervised problem here so we
don't actually know z so we can't
directly just apply back propagation by
supervising on Z so instead let's apply
a trip where we actually trying to
reconstruct the original data so now on
the right hand side you can see a
reconstruction by applying these up
sampling convolutions
into a reconstructed version of the
original data so you can might notice
here that the right hand side is a
blurry version of the left hand side and
that's because we lose some information
by going through such a small latent
space and that's to be expected
that's the whole point of finding what
are the most important features and also
to get rid of noise like was the
suggestion in the audience so here we
denote that reconstruction as X hat
it's just denoting the estimated or
reconstructed version of the input data
we can supervise this by basically just
comparing the output which is the
reconstructed version of the input with
the original input and you might think
of something just like computing the
difference of these two images
subtracting them and computing their
square and adding up all these
differences that will give you a loss
term that we can use in back propagation
just like before so now we're kind of
shifting the problem from a completely
unsupervised problem where we have no
notion of how to create these latent
variable Z now we have some notion of
supervising it end to end and by doing
it end to end this reconstruction loss
is forcing the decoder to learn the most
accurate version or sorry the most rich
latent variable possible so that it can
describe for so that it can reconstruct
the image as as much as possible
right so if this latent space was not
descriptive at all of the image then the
decoder could never create such a such
an accurate image depicting its input so
by forcing it to reconstruct this too
you're forcing the lane space to be very
rich in its latent variables right and
just to reiterate it again this loss
function does not require any labels
we're not telling it that it's a two
here we're simply feeding it images of
twos or or whatever numbers and we're
learning the underlying latent variables
associated with this data now let's just
start abstracting away this image a
little bit so we can get more complexity
here I'm removing all of the
convolutional layers and I'm just
drawing the encoder with a single
trapezoid so basically denoting that
we're going from this X
to a low dimensional Z and then going
from Z to a higher dimensional X hat and
reconstructing it and this idea of
bottlenecking the network forcing all of
the activations and all of the
information to be bottle necked into
this Lane space is essentially this idea
of compression Auto encoding is a form
of compression and basically smaller
latent spaces will result in noisier and
noisier or should I say blurrier and
blurrier outputs the more bottleneck
that you apply on the network means the
smaller that your latent space will
become and the result applied on n this
you can see something like this so if
you only have two two variables in your
latent space you can abstract away a
little bit of the problem you can still
generate the images but you're losing a
lot of the crisp detail in the images so
you still get the high level structure
of what's going on here but you're
missing a lot of the details increasing
that up to five dimensional now you can
alway already see a lot of the details
that you had previously lost and
comparing that to ground truth you can
at least for these low dimensional
inputs it's very close at human high
level so in summary auto-encoders
utilize this bottleneck layer to
actually learn the rich representation
of the latent space and that forces the
network to learn a hidden representation
of the data it's a self supervising
approach because the latent loss that
actually forces the network to encode as
much information as possible in the data
in order to reconstruct it later on in
the network and that's where the name
come from so it's called Auto encoding
because it's trying to automatically
encode that data so that it can learn to
reconstruct it as well so now let's
build on this idea in a bit more
advanced a concept called variational
autoencoders which are simply just an
extension on auto-encoders with the
probabilistic spin so let's revisit the
standard auto encoder picture that I
just showed you here at the Leighton
space is a deterministic function right
so all of these layers are completely
deterministic if I feed in the same
input multiple times I will always get
the same output on the other side that's
the definition of determinism what's the
difference in a variational auto encoder
so now in a variational autoencoder
we're replacing that intermediate latent
space which was deterministic now with a
probabilistic or stochastic operation so
instead of predicting a single
deterministic Zee we're now predicting a
single mu and a single Sigma which will
then sample from in order to create a
stochastic Zee
so now if we feed in the same image this
two on the left-hand side multiple times
through the network we'll actually get
different twos appearing on the other
side and that's because of the sampling
operation from the muse and Sigma's that
we predict so again just to reiterate
the muse and Sigma is up until that
point these are computed
deterministically you take this as input
to then compute the stochastic sample of
Z which you then use for the decoding
and like I said before variational
auto-encoders essentially represent a
probabilistic spin on normal or vanilla
autoencoders where we can sample from
the mean and standard deviation of the
distributions that they predict in order
to compute their latent sample so let's
break this up a little bit more so it's
broken up just like a normal autoencoder
into two parts an encoder which takes
the image and produces now the
probabilistic a probabilistic a
probability distribution over the latent
space and as as opposed to before which
was deterministic now we have an actual
probability distribution here
parameterize by these weights phi which
are the parameters of the encoder and we
have a decoder which does the opposite
it takes as it finds a probability
distribution of the data given your
latent distribution and it has
parameters theta and these are just the
parameters of your decoder so you can
think of these parameters as the weights
of the convolutional neural network that
define this decoding operation and this
is V is the weights of the encoder the
weights of
convolutional layers that define the
encoding operation our loss function is
very similar to the loss function in
vanilla
auto-encoders we simply want to compute
the reconstruction loss like before that
forces this bottleneck layer to learn a
rich representation of the latent space
but now we also have this other term
which is called a regularization term or
a or sometimes it's called like the VA
II lost because it's specific to VA es
so what is this let's take a look at
this in a bit more detail so like I said
the loss function here is comprised of
inputs from both the encoder and the
decoder
it also takes us input the input data X
and it wants to actually by training
this you want to learn some loss
function that's a weighted sum between
the reconstructions and your latent loss
reconstruction is the same as before you
can think of it as just a pixel wise
difference between your inputs and your
outputs and you self supervise them to
force the lane spaces to learn the
regularization term here is a bit more
interesting so let's touch on it in a
little more detail before moving forward
so Phi or the probability distribution
Phi of Z given X is the probability
distribution it's the distribution of
the encoder it's the distribution of
your latent space given your data and
it's computed like I said by the encoder
as part of regularizing we want to place
a fixed prior on this distribution to
make sure that the Z's that we compute
follows some prior that we define so
essentially what this term here is
describing is d stands for distance so
the regularization term is minimizing
the distance between our inferred
distribution which is the Meuse and
sigmaz that we learn and we want to
minimize the distance between that
distribution and a distribution prior
distribution that we define I haven't
told you what that prior is yet and
we'll get to that soon so a common
choice of a prior here
a very common choice for VA E's and
specific
is to make this prior a normal Gaussian
prior so we want it to be centered at
meeting zero and standard deviation 1
what this does it basically encourages
our latent space or it encourages our
encoder to project all of the input
images or all of our input data in
general into a latent space which is
centered at zero and has roughly a
variance of 1 if the network tries to
deviate from that and place images on
different parts of latent space
potentially by trying to memorize or
cheat and put special inputs in
different parts of the latent space it's
going to be penalized for doing that
it's going to be kind of constrained to
work only in this probabilistic setting
by following this Gaussian normal
Gaussian prior and like we saw it's very
similar in the cross entropy loss we can
actually define this distance function
that we can use to regularize our neural
network or VI e and if we're using this
case like I said before where we want to
place a prior on a zero one normal
Gaussian it's just going to take this
form between the predicted muse and
sigmaz and we want to constrain those
Meuse and sigmaz to be as close as
possible to a normal Gaussian of zero
and one sometimes you'll see this term
denoted the KL divergence of the data
and and that's where this comes from
great so now we've defined our loss
function that lets us know how we can
actually train this network using back
propagation and reconstruct the inputs
and how that actually different differs
from a vanilla auto encoder the
regularization term here is taken care
of and we can use it with a normal
Gaussian prior let's assume for the rest
of this lecture but we actually still
have a big problem here so I've defined
the forward pass for you pretty clearly
I have to find the sampling operation
between the muse and the Sigma's to
create these Z's but I think I forgot a
very important step which is one of the
reasons why VA E's were never being used
until a few years ago because you could
never actually back propagate gradients
through a sampling layer so these
sampling layers that take as input stuff
deterministic and using Sigma's an
output a stochastic sample at the output
you can compute their forward pass it's
simple but then if you want a back
propagate through a sampling node
there's no notion of back propagation
through stochastic nodes or layers and
one of the key ideas that occurred about
a few years ago
was this idea of reprioritizing reaper a
motorizing the sampling layer so that
you could perform back propagation
through it and train this network and to
end I'll quickly give you a brief intro
or introduction to how the repairment
translation trick occurs so we already
learned that we can't just simply sample
from this distribution in a backward
pass because we can't compute that
backwards pass and we can't compute a
channel through it so let's instead
consider a different alternative which
is let's sample the latent vector as a
sum between the Meuse and the Sigma's so
we'll start with the Mews these are the
means of the distribution we'll add
those to a weighted version of the Sigma
vectors which is the standard deviation
and we'll just scale those standard
deviations by a random number which we
can normally which we can draw from a
normal distribution 0 1 so we still have
a stochastic node here because we're
doing this this sampling of epsilon but
the difference here is the sampling is
actually not occurring within the layer
itself it's occurring as a by-product
we're reaper amat rising where the
sampling is occurring so instead of a
cry instead of sampling directly within
this see you can imagine the sampling
occurring off to the side and being fed
into the sampling layer so let's take a
look at what that might look like so in
the original example we have
deterministic nodes which are just the
weights of the network and the input
data that we have and we have a sampling
layer which takes those two to compute a
sample according to the distribution
defined by the encoder we already
learned that we can't do back propagate
we can't do propagation through this
layer because of because of the nature
of the sampling node and it's not
deterministic so when we Reaper it
we get a chart that looks like this
which is a lot nicer and now if you look
at it we have the same encoder weights
we have the same data but now our
sampling node has moved off to the side
okay so the sampling node is being drawn
from normal distribution 0 1 and Z is
now deterministic with respect to that
sampling node okay so now when we want
to do back propagation and actually back
propagate gradients to update our
encoder because this is ultimately what
we want to back propagate gradients to
these are the weights of the neural
network that we want to update when we
back propagate we can back propagate
through this z now because these epsilon
czar just taken as constants so we don't
need to back propagate in this direction
if we did then that would be a problem
because this is a sampling node again
but we don't care about that we want to
back propagate this way now this is a
really powerful idea it lets us now
train these variational auto-encoders
end to end and since we impose these
distributional priors on them we can
actually slowly increase or decrease
latent variables that we learn to get
some really cool features of the output
and basically by taking a latent vector
you fix all of the data except for one
variable in that vector and you
basically increase or decrease that
variable and then you run the decoder
each time you increase or decrease it
and you can see that the output actually
has some semantic meaning so what does
it look like this variable is actually
capturing does anyone see it yeah
exactly it's the tilt of the face or the
pose of the face on the left hand side
the face is pointing to the right and on
the right hand side the face is pointing
on the left and as you move from left to
right you can see the face kind of
turning and it's a smooth transition and
you can actually do this because the
latent variables are continuous in
nature they're following that normal
distribution and you can just walk along
them and create the output at each step
this is just one example of a latent
variable but the network is learning
many different latent variables it's
that whole vector Z that we showed
before and each of these vector each of
these elements in Z is encoding a
different interpreted latent feature
ideally we want these features to be
independent and uncorrelated with each
other so that we can actually have we
can walk along each dimension and
observe different semantic meanings so
here's the same example as before where
we're walking left and right an
observing head pose we can also walk up
and down and observe something like
smile so these are all again fake images
this person doesn't exist but you can
actually create and remove smiles and
change the position of their head just
by perturbing these two numbers this is
the idea of disentanglement so when you
have two variables that are uncorrelated
with each other and when affecting one
of them affects some semantic meaning or
changing one of them affects some
semantic meaning and changing the other
one it affects a different semantic
meaning when those two semantic meanings
are disentangled that's when these
variables are uncorrelated with each
other right so those were in exam that
was an example for images
here's another pretty cool example for
music so let's see if this plays so here
the four quadrants are representing
different positions in the latent space
so this quadrant is one particular song
this quadrant is another particular song
and you're using now your auto encoder
to actually interpolate and walk
anywhere in this space so currently
we're at this location and we can just
move where we're sampling from and
generate brand new music that's
essentially an interpolation between any
of these songs so here's an example
so now you're moving down and the song
changes to the other style right so
going back to images we can get the same
idea again going back to endless we can
walk along different dimensions of a
two-dimensional amnesty problem and
observe that we can sample an
interpolation between the different
endless figures and actually see these
really cool visualizations where we can
generate all the different figures from
just two latent variables right ok so
just to summarize now in VI use we learn
to compress the world down into some low
dimensional latent space that we can use
to learn we learned that reconstruction
allows for unsupervised learning without
labels read parameterization trick to
actually train these networks end to end
and interpret the hidden layer hidden
latent variables using perturbations and
increasing and decreasing them
iteratively to actually generate brand
new examples so now the question I'd
like to bring up is in VA ease we
brought up density estimation as core
now we'll transition to a new type of
models called generative adversarial
networks which are focused on a slightly
different problem and that's focused
mainly on sample generation so now
you're not concerned as much with
estimating the density of your
distribution but you care more about
just generating samples at the output
and the key idea here is that you have
the same Z this encoding but now in
generative adversarial networks there's
not as much semantic meaning as there
was in via is instead you're just
feeding in raw noise so it's just a
random noise label just a random noise
vector and you train you want to train
this generator to predict these fake
images at the output you want these fake
images to be as close as possible
- the real images from your training
distribution and the way we can do this
is actually using generative adversarial
networks which we have this generator on
the bottom generating fake images we
have a discriminator which is taking in
the fake images and also the real images
and learning to distinguish between fake
and real and by having these two neural
networks - generator and discriminator
compete against each other you force the
discriminator to learn how to
distinguish between real and fake and
the better that the discriminator
becomes at distinguishing real from fake
it forces the generator to produce
better and better or more realistic and
more realistic fake examples to keep
fooling the generator so let's walk
through a really quick example a toy
example on the intuition behind guns so
the generator starts from noise and a
crowd tries to create some imitation of
data so here's one dimensional data is
trying to just just generate some random
data because it hasn't been trained so
these are the points on a one
dimensional line of fake data the
discriminator sees these points but it
also sees some real data
now you train the discriminator to
recognize what is the probability that
this is real the discriminator knows
what's real and what's fake so you train
it to recognize what's real and what's
fake and in the beginning again it's not
trained but then you train it and it
starts increasing the probabilities what
of what's real decreasing the
probabilities of what's fake until you
get this perfect separation point where
the discriminator is able to separate
and distinguish what is real from what
is fake now the generator comes back and
sees how well the discriminator is doing
and it tries to move its generated
points closer to the real data to start
fooling the generator to start fooling
the discriminator
so now it's moving those points closer
and closer to the green points now let's
go back to the discriminator
discriminator gets these new points now
its previous predictions are a little
bit messed up right so it's it's used to
seeing some of those red points farther
away it you can retrain it now it can
learn again decreasing the probability
of those red points coming in
increasing the probability of those
green or real points even more and we
repeat again now the generator one last
time starts moving those points even
closer to the real distribution what you
can see here is now that the points are
following almost in this toy example the
same distribution as the real data and
it's very hard for the discriminator to
distinguish between what is real and
what is fake and that's the idea behind
ganz so get in ganz we have a
discriminator just to summarize a
discriminator that is trying to identify
real from fake
well the generator tries to imitate real
data and fooled the discriminator this
can be formalizing using a min/max
objective function where the
discriminator d so the the parameters of
the discriminator d is trying to
maximize the likelihood objective and
increase the chances that this term on
the left this is the probability that
the real data is as close as possible to
one and it wants to also get this so
let's get this probability as close as
possible to one it wants to get this
probability as close as possible to zero
because that's the probability of seeing
fake data and on the other hand the
generator now which is theta g tries to
change its weights in order to maximize
that same objective so i minimize that
same objective so now it's going to
change its weights theta g inside of
here to generate new fake data that is
going to fool that generate that
discriminator so briefly what are the
benefits of gans as opposed to
variational autoencoder these are two
versions of very latent variable models
but there are some benefits to using
gans as opposed to VA e's imagine we're
trying to fit a model to this latent
manifold which you can see cartoon ax
fide here so if we're using a
traditional maximum likelihood
estimation we can see on the left-hand
side that we're having a very fuzzy
estimation here it's noisy and it's kind
of taking a smooth round not really
capturing a lot of the details of the
manifold the difference here is that
again
it's not using a maximum likelihood
estimate it's using this minimax
formulation between two neural networks
it's able to capture a lot of the
details and the nooks and crannies of
this manifold in that sense it's able to
create a lot crisper or it's able to
model a lot more detail in the real data
so let's explore what we can generate
with this new data and this actually
leads nicely into a lot of the recent
advances that Gant's have enjoyed in the
past couple of years and I'll talk about
some results even in the past couple
months that are really astonishing and
that starts with this idea from earlier
2018 involving the progressive growth of
Bret against so the idea here is that
you want to iteratively build more and
more detailed image generators so you
start your generator by just predicting
4x4 images very coarse-grained images
not detailed at all but when you start
with this it's able to learn a
representation a very coarse-grained
representation of how to generate these
coarse images once the generator has a
good intuition on this coarse-grained
representation you start progressively
growing its dimensionality and start
progressively adding new and new layers
and increasing the spatial resolution of
the generator this is good because it's
able to stable the synthesis of the
output and also it actually ends up
speeding up training as well and it's
able to create these high-resolution
input outputs at the end 1000 by a
thousand images that are very realistic
again these weren't the images that I
showed you I'll get to those in a second
but these are still incredibly realistic
images and here's some more examples of
that same network producing those images
the same team actually released another
paper just a month ago where they create
an extension of this work to a more
complex architecture that builds on this
work this progressive growing of gans to
actually use what they call a style
based approach where they're actually
using the underlying style which you can
think of as like a latent variable of
the faces and using that as an
intermediate
mapping to automatically learn
unsupervised separation of the
high-level attributes such as the pose
or like the subjects hair or skin color
etc as a result this approach which you
can see generated examples here these
are not a real examples these are fake
or generated examples the model is able
to generate highly varied outputs that
highlight that represent very realistic
human faces so the idea behind style
transfer is actually have the generator
transfer styles from a source image
which you can see on the top row so
these are source images to a destination
image which you can see on the right
hand side and it's taking the features
from the source image and applying it to
the destination image and it's actually
able to realize in certain cases that if
you try and apply it a male's face to a
female it actually realized that
something is wrong and starts to add
male features to this face it realizes
that something's wrong so it starts to
add a beard here even though there was
no beard on this destination image and
it's things like this that you're
actually understanding that it's able to
get some intuition about the underlying
distribution of males and females males
have beards facial hair whereas females
typically don't and there are other
examples here as well it's really
remarkable work transforming skin color
hair color even like patterns on the
face to very fine-grained details in the
in the image in the output image and
finally one very last applications I'll
touch on here is this notion of cycle
gang which is the idea of having
unpaired image to image translation
which is very closely related to what we
just discussed in the progressive
growing of Gans through styles and what
we want to do here is actually take a
bunch of images in one domain and
without having the corresponding image
in the say in a different domain we want
to just learn a generator to take an
image in one domain generate a new image
so take an image in Ex generate a new
image and why following wise
distribution and likewise take
image of why created an image in X and
the way they actually do this a really
cool advancement of this paper was what
they did was they actually created this
cycle lost the cycle consistency that
the network has to abide by where and if
they create going from X to Y they then
take that same generated output and go
back from Y to X and check how close
they are to the original input data and
they enforce another supervised loss
using that and that's why they call this
approach cycle again because you're
creating the cycle loss between the two
generators and you also have these two
discriminators that are trying to
distinguish real from fake in each of
those distributions and what you're able
to do is actually transfer domains from
unpaired images like horses on the left
hand side and you're now taking that
horse and making it into a zebra okay so
this is just taking images of a lot of
horses and a lot of zebras and without
actually supervising how to go from
horse to zebra it learns the underlying
distribution of what's a horse
what's a zebra so you can take a new
image of a horse and make it look like a
zebra and it's actually really
interesting here because you might
notice the obvious thing which is its
adding stripes what I actually noticed
here was even more interesting with it's
changing the color of the grass which if
you think about why is it doing this
zebras are typically found in drier
climates for example like in in Africa
zebras are often found and the grass in
these climates is probably not as green
as the one that this horse is it so it's
actually realizing not just the details
of the horse going to the zebra stripes
but also realizing the surroundings of
the horse and transferring these details
as well so finally I'll just summarize
this lecture and conclude we covered two
main techniques for generative modeling
focusing first on variational
autoencoders which are which we
introduce as latent variable models here
we try to learn a low dimensional input
or sorry although dimensional latent
space of our input so we can actually
get some intuition and interpretation
behind the underlying data distribution
then we extended this idea into gans
which is another form of
variable models but one now trained
between a minimax game using a generator
and the discriminator to complete to
create even more complex outputs or
generated samples from the distributions
and that's it
thank you
[Applause]